you talk about academic freedom we
discuss that quite frequently on this on
this very podcast what does it mean to
you and is it relevant today concerning
the situation with with academic freedom
you see the bigger question that I
regard in this book in particular but
that always has been very close to my
heart is what I would call intellectual
freedom which is a little bit even more
than academic freedom I mean it's not
just you know your ability to research
what you want and publish what you want
and so on but it is really it ties into
into things even like freedom of speech
you know but you should be entitled to
your opinions too and that's part of
what I call you also intellectual
freedom and Galileo's fight was largely
a fight for intellectual freedom it is
often described as if it was a clash
between science and religion which in
fact it wasn't in Galileo never saw it
as such it was Galileo you know like all
people at his age were it was a
religious person his main point was that
the Bible is not a science book it was
written for the salvation of humans and
not to teach them science he pointed out
that you know in the case of astronomy
for example the planets aren't even
named in the Bible and the language used
he said was such that common people will
be able to understand it
[Music]